so i just want to clarify for everyone
watching us that as a child you were
diagnosed
with an auditory processing disorder and
a speech impediment
can you explain what that is and how
it shaped your life because now you
speak
perfectly and so it's hard to imagine
what you were before what your speech
was like before
well i was born early along with my twin
and a lot of times
for infants that can lead to learning
delays
and so one of my delays was in speech
and speech pronunciation
and also just the auditory um processing
issue just means that
i really struggle as an auditory learner
but
what that also meant is the the learning
process by which
at a certain age kids are saying r
and sh and those were a lot of the
sounds that i would still struggle with
specifically
are because it is one of the most
complex letters in the english alphabet
that was something that
i would struggle with until probably 20
years of
age and when you have a last name like
gorman
when you are writing poetry all the
things that constitute my identity when
you go to a school like harvard
which has two r's in it it leads to all
of these kind of
roadblocks but i'm really grateful
actually for that experience because it
informs my poetry
and i think it made me all that much
stronger of a writer
when you have to teach yourself how to
say words from scratch
when you are learning through poetry how
to speak
english it lent to a great understanding
i think of sound
of pitch of pronunciation so i think
of my speech impediment not as a
weakness or disability but as one of my
greatest strengths
you